you knew him well of course he was a
force to be reckoned with wasn't he
uh to say i knew max well might be
stretching it i mean obviously i was
involved with
uh formula one at a very crucial time
when max made a name for himself in
uh campaigning for safety after the
death of air and senator and roland
ratzenberger he was very effective
in bringing in the changes that need to
be needed to be made
um but he also worked very closely with
the commercial wing of formula one with
bernie ecclestone and he and bernie were
a team
that uh wielded quite a lot of influence
it's fair to say
over the support i mean i think i my
opinion of max might be slightly jaded
um because um some of the opinions are
some of the decisions that were made
when i was racing
i might not have agreed with um but he
wasn't afraid of
making decisions and and some of them
quite audacious
um for instance the hundred million
dollar fine of of mclaren
um was was one which was caught the
attention of a lot of people
yeah and you mentioned uh safety
and the fact that you were cena's
teammate in that 1994 season
uh sport the sport needed to change
didn't it at that point
absolutely and i think that uh there was
panic in the air and i think that he was
quite decisive and and uh and he knew
quite clearly he could see quite clearly
what needed to be done he's training as
a lawyer i think
helped him enormously in that sense and
his political skills
in saying the right things and doing the
right thing so that formula one wasn't
um restricted or legislated against
because it would have been very easy at
that time for the
the sport to to come under uh uh
uh some penalties perhaps even and and
restrictions that they wouldn't have
liked so he fought back and he
uh chan he made the changes necessary in
advance of anyone
legislating against them so formula one
if you think about the safety aspects of
formula one the changes that were
brought in i think the
the fact that uh roman grosjean managed
to survive his accident in bahrain last
year
can be linked directly to the changes
that were brought in under max mosley
and the team and formula one and and
steve watkins
and all the people who work on the
safety side and i guess that was shaped
as well by the fact that he had done
some racing himself hadn't in the 60s
yes and he was shocked by the uh
callousness perhaps
is a word i think he used about uh
racing because there was a lot of young
guys competing in
formula form of three and uh formula two
at his level and
who were dying and and nothing was done
about it so he was
he was i think quite uh he said quite
moved about
uh those those losses and i think that
he
resolved that he was going to do
something about it i mean of course it
would be wrong to
suggest that um uh that max was
was much much much loved by everyone in
the sport he was not
afraid of uh of standing up to
or creating divisions in the sport and
some people strongly objected to some of
the
uh the the decisions that he made and
uh so there was definitely some some
different camps and the different
opinions about his
um uh his rule of of formula one
um but no one can deny that he was an
extremely bright
individual who who got things done and
and worked for the sport in many other
areas
yeah and he was re-elected three times
wasn't he which which i guess
shows that he was having success
yes i think that he was probably a bit
like um
shooting fish in a barrel for max
actually you know keeping uh
keeping his reins on on power in in the
fia
um but um you know i think he was he i
think he was frustrated
uh it seemed to me that he was prevented
from
acting in the real political world and
because of his legacy because of his
parentage and because of his perhaps
controversial
political ties yeah
oh have we uh have we lost damon there i
think we might have done what a shame
uh damon hill well oh you're you're back
you're back damon i i just wanted to ask
you you talked to you talked a bit
a little bit about his controversial
past and i know you don't want to talk
about his his privacy
campaigning but but i suppose uh the
fact that he did fight
so hard uh against the news of the world
and against others who felt that they'd
been on the wrong end of the press
it says something about his character
doesn't it
well i mean extremely strong character
and extremely uh
resilient as well i mean not many people
could have endured what he
what he put himself through and uh he
wasn't afraid to fight back and and i
think that uh
that's what you'd say he was a
formidable individual
and someone who didn't trifle with
lightly
so extremely bright guy and extremely
determined to
to get his way